Start of the summer.
Right, it's real quick. Okay, cool. Yeah.
So, yeah, I think from from our end, this is good. Most folks.
We might have a few folks pop in and out per availability, but I think this is kind of a core group.
So, I will say, I know we talked a little bit. All the reporting we get comes from multiple sources.
And I think Ron can tell you this as well. Some of the sources are good.
Some of them are not great. I know you talked to Rick earlier about the SSIS jobs.
So, like, as I'm sure you saw, some of those processes are a little.
Outdated, let's say, in a nice way, or not the best to do what they do. So, I wouldn't want whatever CDP we build to consume the end result of that.
But I think knowing what SSIS is doing is good. So, you can pick out the pieces that you want as it comes in as raw data versus it's been manipulated.
So, I feel that we may have to do that with some of the reporting stuff too.
But again, Ron knows that data real well. So, I don't know which area you want to start in. Questions you have, and I'm sure Ron can answer this for you.
Cool. I think Ron probably has a good idea of a lay of the land and some high levels to get the conversation started.
And then we can probably dig in. But I have heard about Guice, and that was one of the things that seemed pretty important to get into as well.
Yeah, just for reference, Guice is just a reporting engine. It's like a Power BI or something.
So, really, the main goal of Guice originally was to be able to build reports without engineering involvement.
Because once Ron said, here's the database and here's the view you need, they kind of just drag and drop elements and it makes it really easy for them.
So, that's really Guice. So, I wouldn't want to say Guice is a big important thing, because we'll probably end up dropping Guice here soon.
But the data underlying those reports is where the goal is.
Got it.
Guice has a very specific problem, which is it's not capable of doing joins.
So, when we have data from multiple sources, we have to pull them into DWRPT, do the join at the SQL level, and then present a view to Guice.
And admittedly, we've discovered some of our data isn't quite as clean as we would like it to be.
And we've implemented things like Common Client ID to be able to join these tables better.
Okay. So, that was actually one of the questions, is how important is Guice for the longer-term roadmap?
Yeah, it's not.
If we can replace it with something better, I'd be on board with that. And I think we already are, in some ways, looking at alternatives.
Who are the consumers of Guice, the reports, and who are the people who build them? And are they the same group of people?
No. So, the reports are meant to be client-facing. So, our clients look at these reports, or we export them and send them to their clients.
The people who are building them are an internal product team, specifically Jacob, the guy who's putting this together.
Some of the other product people have put some together here and there, but Jacob's the main one for designing and building these out.
And again, non-technical, it's the drag-and-drop type of it.
Got it. I haven't checked, and this is my bad. Do we have access to Guice?
You won't have access to Guice, because, again, Guice is just a report builder.
But we could, and I think Ron was working on getting you access to the data warehouse reporting database,
which has all the tables and data that runs and powers the analytics in Guice, which is just, again, a UI to look at the reports.
Can we get maybe an example report that is generated through…
Yeah, you know what? I have it pulled up right now. Let me share my screen.
So, this is the 3Birds. We purchased 3Birds a long time ago, so it's Dash technology now, but 3Birds is a CDXP site.
There's a bunch of different reports under here. This is just one of them.
But you can see, you can filter, it's got reports, just data points, tables.
You can search by certain campaign methods, let me see any of the ones that are scheduled, filters them, stuff like that.
Little tabs. So, this is kind of what a Guice report looks like.
You can filter them, look at specific things. It's just tables and cards and stuff like that.
It's pretty straightforward. You can click on these and it'll filter these down.
So, you can say, oh, let me only see the SMS ones, and it'll filter this report down to only show you the SMS.
Click off it, it'll show you everything.
So, this is what a Guice report looks like.
It's just, again, same as Power BI. I was trying to see if I could get into this for you.
I'm going to have to probably get a 2FA code, so bear with me a second, and I'll show you the back end of Guice.
And then you can kind of see the reports or the databases and views that kind of runs put together with the team or for the team.
Let's make code.
So, there's about apparently 221 reports. I have not been here in a long time.
So, here's a sample one, I guess. You can view it, and this is kind of what this would look like, I guess.
It's kind of a DDE someone's obviously working on.
Change a client or whatever, get multiple clients.
But realistically, if you wanted to come in and edit this, I'm not going to mess with it because it's something's report that I'm actually messing with.
You can see I can come and drag and drop pieces and change text.
And this is the particular data set that this person's looking at.
And then you can also see that there's different databases that have been hooked up and different views within those databases.
So, hypothetically, I could say I'm going to add in, maybe, I think it's this one, right?
Should be data staging.
So, this would help if I was a product person, I'd come in here and say, okay, I want this database.
Here's the view I want. I want the view on MediaLogic's Google data.
I can add table, and then I'll add the table for the cache so that way I could use it in the report.
So, that's kind of how this works. It's pretty, and then again, it would show up here, and it would have data in it.
I don't know why this one doesn't have data. Let me try a different report.
And the data warehouse does have multiple schemas in there, and we divide up the data that we get from each individual application by that schema.
So, social logic will be in the SL schema, MediaLogic's in the ML schema.
They have some overlap in them, which is why we do that, so that we make sure we don't convolute the data.
Okay. And you embed this in your own kind of portal and expose, or does it just kind of let you customize it in your mind?
So, you can customize this UI in the back end when you do the reporting.
We kind of have a base set that we use that always has data technology at the top, always has our oranges or whatever.
But then, this is just iframed in. Like, we inspect this page. It's just an iframe.
There is specific security around it. Like, you have to log in, and we have to log you in and all this stuff.
Right here, you can see it's just an iframe, right? So, we're iframing it in.
But there are, like, rules around it. This is how they do it at embed.
We're not specifically iframing it. There is a way, but it comes in and it's an iframe, inevitably.
And again, you can see, so there's some data from this particular survey send view that Ron's created to run this report.
You can see there's all these different elements in there. It kind of goes along as well.
But, what's the best UI? I don't necessarily like it.
But anyway, this is what the CDXP team was kind of integrating with when we purchased them.
So, we kind of moved forward with this.
We do have Power BI here. We don't necessarily have Power BI developers, and that was a problem.
It was like taking Ron's time away from something to try and get it done, or steal an engineer to try and do it.
It was taking up too much time, so we ended up paying our offshore team to do it.
It was taking up too much time.
So, they ended up utilizing something like this, so we could have an easy place for a product team to come and build reports.
I don't know why it's taking so long to load.
But again, you go and add the views of data you want, and then you can come.
You can see it here if you wanted, but then at this point, if I wanted to, like, say, load this piece of data up.
Each one of these is an element, and then each one of those breaks down to – this is a sum of total reviews, right?
So, I click on this, and you can see it's summing total reviews from the specific view all-time performance table.
So, they're going through and doing this stuff.
But it's all drag and drop and click, and pretty straightforward, no real engineering needed.
And a lot of times, they copy and paste stuff from other reports.
So, this is kind of what Juice is as a whole.
Not something I think we need to keep, per se.
There could be way better other reporting things if we want to spend the money, but this is what we have today.
Cool. Thank you for that overview.
And I think what would be useful – Ron, do you have the data warehouse reporting database up that you can show them real quick?
I don't. I wasn't set for that, so give me a few minutes to get in there.
Okay. Yeah, and then maybe he can give you a quick overview of what that schema is,
because he does stuff into staging tables and then moves them into specific views and stuff.
And he's doing a lot of that through ADF.
Ron manages a lot of Azure Data Factory moves.
One thing to note as well is, most of our stuff –
is in Azure, the CDXP app that I was showing you where those reports lived, that app is technically
in AWS, and there's one other app we have called Engage to Sell, which is part of our AI
engagement messaging that's also in AWS. So we have two, those are the two AWS systems right now,
mainly because when we bought them they were in AWS and we just haven't done yet.
And all the other bunches of databases and data sources in AWS that powers the CDXP system?
Yes, correct. Everything that's in the AWS, except for the Engage to Sell stuff,
Engage to Sell is in our own region in our AWS account. Those two apps have their own databases
that, you know, that engages, sorry, CDXP actually has several databases, as I think you probably saw
in that initial schema doc I kind of sent, there's a lot of different stuff in there,
and it goes to multiple different databases. They have Postgres, I think, for some of their
reporting stuff. They also have a MySQL and they have some SQL, and there's multiple databases on
the one server because it bounces from like stage to target to prod or whatever, you know,
they've got a bunch of stuff going on there through those SSIS jobs, I'm sure Rick showed you earlier
today. Quite messy, to be honest, there's a lot of moving pieces, but yeah.
So I can share?
Yeah.
So the data warehouse currently, it's pretty straightforward. So we use data staging as our
data stage for everything coming in. The tables themselves are direct copies by ADF from our
various applications. And like I said, the schema that you will see is specific to that application.
So CDXP data that comes in is listed as CDXP.JuiceReporting, you know, what they're,
what we're pulling from them. And we have CDXP ClientDB Core, which is social logics.
Some dynamics information, some stuff that we get directly from Google,
lot vantage, media logic, and response logic, and then some radar views.
So that data, that information in there is core raw data. And from there, we'll drop down to views,
so we don't combine the data by stored procedure, we combine the data is through views.
And AI specific views are for AI analytical tools. We give them a similar data set to juice,
but we don't join the data together as much. We want the AI system to be able to analyze the core
information. And then we have a few other views like the cores for surveys and reviews, and then
these are all just joined together data points that are coming out of the applications,
so that juice can take it and then manipulate that data. A lot of it is just getting the account
information in there with the common client ID, so that we can get all of our different applications,
some which were acquired, so they have different internal IDs, all using the same common ID for it.
A company or a client that we have. So this is the primary part of the data warehouse that we
are going to, there is some push. As you can see, we have Zora down here, there's going to be
some databases in there that are going to be very isolated, because they contain company proprietary
information like billing. But for the most part, the data warehouse is strictly a data warehouse
of data that exists within each of our applications. This way, our reporting is never, we don't want,
the goal we want is to keep reporting from contacting the production databases directly.
So this will help isolate the source databases and keep them more secure, so we don't have anybody
going in there accidentally changing data or damaging things.
Got it. And then basically everything comes here through ADF kind of jobs, and then
one-to-one with source, and then you aggregate them as views, so that they're
ready and processable in that way. All right. Yeah, and the juice, like I said, can't do
joins, so it can't take two different tables and join them together to produce one dataset.
So we have to do it at the DWRPT level. The difference is AI, we do one-for-one. We give
it the raw data in its views, so that it can do a better analysis. It has more flexibility to do
the analysis of the data that we have in there. Yeah, when he's talking about AI, are you guys
familiar with Javis? Have we told you about Javis yet, Leo?
Doesn't ring an immediate bell. Okay, so it's not necessarily ours, it's something we do with a
third party. And what it is, it's kind of like a chatbot type system that we put over AI. You see
the specific tables are called AI views. That's specific views and tables are created for AI.
So we can ask it questions, and it builds us these really nice visual reports. Let me just
show you an example real quick on the screen for a second. This is Javis. This is an agent Alex
created a while ago, plot review sentiment. So I just gave it a name, it runs through, looks up all
the data, and then pulls me up this nice report. Right, a few views, and stuff like that.
And he's got a couple of different ones like that. I have other examples here,
Bob Palmer, maybe this one as well. This is a different one for lead response. Again,
so it's a way of building on-demand reports, if you will. So the goal with this is we have
specific agents available. We give this access to this thing called Javis, or whatever you want to
call it. It's originally from the customer. We bought it from this called Javis. We paid for this.
It sits over our database right now. It sits over, it can also go to Jira and SharePoint,
help places like that. But mainly what we're using it for is to have on-demand AI reporting.
So not only can you ask it, just give it a name, like again, this one, we give it a name and an ID.
And it went out and built this awesome report with real-time data. You can then do this
and it went out and built this awesome report with real-time data.
You can then do follow-up questions to it, like, I don't know, why did I have I got,
I don't know, question, why did I send more quotes in July than August? And then it'll start telling
you, right? Analyze the shortfall of quotes sent with vehicles. Summarize how these performed low,
you know, and it'll tell you information. So what's cool about this is it not only generates
you really cool reports, you can ask follow-up questions to it. So it's really useful. This is
only used internally right now. But it's really good because it gives recommendations and all
that kind of stuff. So when our internal team is calling out to, say, this Bob Pointer guy,
they can be like, hey, we did receive this many leads and got a great quote open, right? And we
see that you need to be working on, you know, new vehicle quotes, right? So this is what Javis is.
So when Ron was showing you those AI reports, he's talking about AI reporting. This is the
type of tool that he's talking about. And this one is also technically sitting on AWS,
but it's a third-party tool. Is this, I was going to say, was this a tool that you developed
in-house or is it a service? It's a service, it's a SaaS. So we're paying for it for a year
because we wanted something quick. To be fair, could we build this ourselves? Probably nowadays,
cool, a lot of cool stuff. But to get something out really quick, we're just like, yeah, let's
sign up for this. We'll probably have it for a year, and then we'll re-evaluate what we want to
do. But for right now, it's doing a really good job of getting us data in real time. And then,
again, the follow-up questions are some of the real gold in there as well, especially with,
like, some of these that, like, yeah, this one. Some of these will, like, strip, tell you that,
like, so this is negative view analysis. So this is very useful because it's one of these, say,
like, oh, your one sales guy sucks or whatever, like, rude staff behavior, right? And then we do
analysis, and it, like, even tells you, like, one of these words. It's, like, get rid of that guy
now because he's causing all your trouble, you know? I think it was this one. It's kind of funny.
Address specific members' names. These people provide training for termination straightaway
because that's causing you all the negative reviews, you know what I mean? So there's some
really useful stuff that can come out of this. And again, it's something we're paying for right
now. Can we do it ourselves eventually? Yes. But for right now, this is what we're using.
So when he's looking at and showing you those AI views and AI tables, that's specifically for this.
Cool. What's the name of the SaaS tool? So it's from a company called Ascending,
and it's called Jarvis. I mean, we know it is Jarvis, but realistically, we probably shouldn't
call it Jarvis. They don't want us to call it Jarvis. But yeah, I can show it to you. I'm
going to show it in chat here for you. It's a company called Ascending. This company actually
helped us originally with migrations of some data into AWS. We've talked about AWS and AI,
I know. Anyway, long story short, they didn't have it out as a playable tool when we first
started with them. We kind of almost like helped them develop it. But I do that in chat for you.
Ron, you can take it away. I don't know if there was anything else we need to cover on that.
Okay. So what else do you need to know? Obviously, we can probably get you access,
we give them access to that one yet, Ron? No, I had asked you about it. We didn't know whether
you were going to need access to the reporting server or not. Because you have access to the
majority of the source databases, that would be your call whether you want to get into DWRPT or not.
Yeah, I was really trying to get you guys source as opposed to things that may have been manipulated or ADFs at another point.
Not that you don't, if you want it, let me know, we can get you access, but I'd rather give you the source data.
Sounds good.
Maybe just a couple of them so we can figure out what kind of data you need.
I'm sorry, I had a bit of a hard time hearing what you said there.
Yeah, my connection isn't good. I sent Leo a message. Leo, can you please check it?
My connection isn't good.
Don't worry.
Yeah, let me go find that message. I've got a bunch of windows open, so it might take a minute or a second.
I'll ask you later. Yeah, my connection isn't good.
Okay, but yeah, if you guys need access, just let us know and we can get that for you.
Oh, do you have like a report or, yeah, report inventory of the kinds of, you know, insights that you provide and are looking for?
I mean, we have, I don't know, there's 200 and some odd reports in that tool. There's 221 reports.
I assume there's about 100 of those are active reports.
So I can get you some of it if you want.
Trying to get you an export of all 111 that show sign-in required may not be the best use of our time,
but if you want a view of some of them, or maybe I just get you access to the choose to view around or the CDXP,
so you can take a look at some of those reports, maybe that'd be helpful as opposed to exporting everything.
That'd be great. I think Alicia's intent is to also like work backwards to map out like the kind of relationships that you build on the data to figure out like, you know, a good structure.
Did I get that right, Alicia?
Yes, exactly. Thank you.
Now, my, personally, as much as I like the idea of working backwards from the reporting we currently have,
we are aware that some of our reporting has problems,
and that may not be the best thing to do is to work backwards and just find all the same mistakes that have been done before in the past.
We know things like matchbacks coming out of CDXP aren't making a whole lot of sense,
and the problem is they did a join in the CDXP table for their information that overrode all data.
So, they just joined on the customer ID and the latest vehicle,
and that means when one customer owned two vehicles and they had two different service dates,
all the service dates would become whatever the last service date was for both vehicles, and that causes problems.
So, we know there's a little bit of work that needs to be done in there.
We understand that there's a problem, and so working backwards may not necessarily be the best option.
Yeah, that makes sense.
Cool. All right.
Alicia, do you have any additional questions?
I'm good so far.
Great. Luis, you know?
All right. I think we have everything we need out of this conversation.
Maybe one more question. Is there performance issues with the reports or missing data?
There's sometimes missing data. There's definitely the occasional performance issue where it's not the fastest thing in the world.
Ron's done everything he can. Before, it wasn't used. It was other ways.
So, we specifically made use to try and make the tables shorter so they're not as long.
It's just kind of what they need for that report versus, here's everything, and you figure it out, because it was taking way too long to load some of these, and the tables would crash.
It has got a little better with the stuff we've done, but I know there's better options out there.
So, yeah, there are some performance issues.
And again, Ron brought it up. Some of the SIS processes actually truncate tables.
And I think you saw that earlier, they have to go in a specific order.
So, if it gets halfway through and then truncates a table and crashes, well, then all of a sudden that report's got zeros all over it.
So, that's another performance or data problem that we have.
And some of our data that we do get in from our applications is particularly deep.
All the clicks on media that we record will generate a table that can have 100 million rows in it.
And we have to basically chop it up into years to be able to get juice to load it, because juice, after a minute, just says, oh, I can't load it and cancels it.
A little frustrating when that happens.
And the CDXP tables, like I said, they just join entire tables together.
So, I have a table out there that's been causing me some problems that we have to deal with that is 49 million rows, but it's 194 columns.
And it's just too broad and too deep for juice to really handle what it's trying to do.
And the DWRPT server is an 8V CPU, 32 gig machine.
It's more than capable of doing it, other than that you're so damn big.
So, does the data warehouse have all the historicals?
Or do you have like a retention limit on the data that you keep?
We have not tackled the historical data yet, because it's mostly held in our applications as well.
So, when you look at, say, response logic, you'll see the response logic OLTP database and OLT underscore archive.
So, they do hold their own historical data.
We're going to approach that at some point in time, but it has not been a big push for us to fix that yet.
Now, CIM does hold the historical data.
We have an archive for all vehicles that are delisted.
So, some of our databases, we have looked at that and said, okay, this is how we're going to handle it.
Others are DAS acceptor, which is new.
I haven't had a chance to look at how we're going to handle it there.
How many other consumers do you have of the data warehouse?
Is it primarily JUICE or do you have other?
Primarily JUICE and Jarvis.
Okay, got it.
So, and then the individual applications do produce some of their own reports that are emailed out.
Gotcha.
And those are like batch jobs or?
Those are batch jobs, yeah.
Per app or centralized somewhere?
Per app.
Per app for the most part.
Yeah, got it.
Is there kind of usage access and or read versus write metrics that we can pull somewhere?
Like how much data is coming in versus how many reads are being served actively from the warehouse?
From the warehouse?
No, I'm not actively looking at those right at the moment.
From the individual applications, we don't actively monitor it, but we can pull that information.
We could also pull it from DWRPT, which is not something we actively do right at the moment.
We might be able to get some data factory as well to see the runs and times and stuff.
Yeah.
But again, to Ron's point, we're not actively monitoring or like logging and tracking that specific activity on the data warehouse.
Right.
The other one is usage patterns.
Are there any specific spikes or days where the system sees more traffic?
Is it like you say Monday morning, everybody wants to go get a bunch of reports?
I mean, some of it may be seasonal.
Maybe it's like weekend sales.
I don't know.
For my viewpoint when we're looking at that, and just for clarity, I am a systems engineer who kind of backed my way into being a SQL DBA.
So, I did 25 years as a system engineer.
I look at memory usage, CPU usage.
I look at the metrics of the server that it's supporting.
And I know where my spikes are.
The majority of the time, early week, so Monday and Tuesday, we see slightly larger spikes than during the regular week.
But because we're always running these jobs, usually in the morning, but we space them out a little bit and try to avoid our 100% plateaus for CPU utilization, we get it pretty well spread out.
I know I can't reduce the CPU on DWRPT to four CPUs.
I will then plateau and then everything slows down.
So, that's how we determine how large of our servers we're going to have.
Same thing with CIM.
They both peak at around 70% CPU utilization probably four or five times a day.
Got it.
Cool.
Luis, do you have anything else?
I'm fine.
All right.
Awesome.
Well, I mean, obviously, if anything comes up, feel free to reach out.
Reach out to me.
I can direct you to whoever you need or get you in touch with whomever you need.
And we'll keep getting you access to databases.
I know Ron's working through a couple more.
So, before the end of this week, we'll have probably like five more to go look at.
And I guess off topic a little bit, but Leo, I know we're like coming up Wednesday.
We'll be like two weeks into this project.
So, I don't know if you want to – how you're feeling with things.